hi everyone welcome to another a pack
developer office hours for those of you
who haven't joined us before this is
basically a section where you can ask us
questions live on Android development
and we can do our best to answer them
live or what we actually recommend is
that you post your questions ahead of
time and we provide a moderator link for
that a google moderator link the best
way to tune into this is through
developers.google.com/live and you'll
see all of the other office hours style
event or or google developer live events
including the android ones so thanks for
joining in today i'm joined here this
week by Anirudh Dewani from bangalore hi
guys are such behavior but from the
Hyderabad I'm sorry Aneurin it's hard to
keep track of your trouble and I and I
often make mistakes I apologize anyway
it's great to be joining in web kamala
fee and I am of course Ankur Kotwal and
I'm joining you from Sydney Australia
today I'm in a secret closet well it's
not really a closet but it feels like
one ah and yeah so hopefully if you've
been having a good day and a good week
so far so what we usually do is we we go
to the Google moderator link we bring
that up and we start looking at the
questions so I'm just going to go ahead
and do that today we're going to try
something different we're going to try
screen sharing on google+ now this could
of course blow up in our faces but I
suspect it should be ok so let me try
that let's go screen share and we will
bring up the questions and today we have
nine questions and you know people are
voted on them so it's not too late to
submit questions for for today
session this is live so we will we will
before we wrap up for the day we will go
and check those questions again so let's
get started then the first question is
looking at the API is available is there
a Hangout API for web sorry there is a
Hangout API for web and in Google+ SDK
for Android coming soon is there any
plans to expose g+ hangouts in the
Google+ SDK and if so roughly when will
this functionality via enabled and
that's a good question before I answer
it I just want to also bring up the next
question because it's it's related and
it's this one here that says any word on
when the Android SDK for Google+ will be
available for download so we've we've
mentioned this before that we actually
can't share any any date with with you
externally we when it's ready and
available we will make the the SDK
public and available for all of you so
let me just bring up developers google
com / mobile this is basically where the
Google+ SDK will be found and it's not
out yet we it's coming soon for Android
as was mentioned and as I said we can't
we can't really speak to the dates and
the honest truth is annular than I don't
actually know the dates so we would
probably be lying if we made something
up and we can get in trouble for that so
we'd rather not basically here you'll
find that that it's this is where you'll
find the SDK when it's released and
don't you worry we'll be very vocal
about it so you'll know that it's out
but whilst it's is still baking you can
go and have a look at this page and
you'll see that it actually describes
what api's are going to be available at
the time of release so I guess I'll just
go through them quickly there'll be a
sign in with Google+
so you can use the identity management
side of things and you'll be able to
allow users to share content from within
your apps of course the +1 button will
be there to allow users to to engage on
google+ through your app we also have
something you call the history API and
we have a personalization so they'll
there's some API is there you'll notice
that we haven't made any mention of the
Hangout API Wow the honest truth is I
don't know whether there will be a
hangout API if I did I probably couldn't
tell you about it so anyways the Google+
mobile SDKs for free Android it is
coming soon and you should just stay
tuned ok let us go back to the questions
ah such back and here we are so that's
the first two questions there that we've
answered the next one have are there any
plans to provide real multi-session on
tablets and ap is how about some
services for games to save the
Preferences of the user and saves my
cloud level so that they can continue
either on tablet or phone that's a very
good question hi Andrew hi I will finish
answering this question and it looks
like the next one is from you anyway so
I will get to you in a minute Morris
actually we just answered one from you
regarding the Android SDK for Google+
yes so however yeah good so
multi-session API is on on tablets as I
said this is one of those another one of
those hey what's happening in the future
type things you know it is it what
you're suggesting sounds like a really
useful idea and so we don't have
anything to share right now about
whether such an API exists or is coming
in the future it's certainly not
available now but part of it is and that
part is the saves on a cloud level
right now there's probably two ways that
you could tackle this one is using the
backup service on Android so basically
you can your app can back up some
information to the cloud and then you
know when you fire up the app on on
other devices you can restore that data
keep in mind it's not really designed
for real-time seeking but you might find
that it's sufficient for what you're
trying to do and it really depends on
your situation the other way you could
do it is is through things like the the
Google Drive SDK and use the the google
drive the users Google Drive as a way of
you know storing your data and then
pulling it down and syncing with the
cloud there was a really good
presentation at google io 2012 this year
on using the Google Drive SDK on android
so I would suggest you you have a look
at that and see where it where it lands
you um is there anything else you want
to add to that onion oh yeah thank you
go at it pretty well so we don't have
any real pine Club backing up for the
session but you can save your
preferences using one of the options
which is the mac up API but it's not
real dying and then you can use the
right which can be real time it's one
cool good right um Andrew it seems like
someone's bumped you so I'll just get to
them and then I'll get to you hopefully
they don't bump you again that's our all
right uh we have a question from our pit
who says I'm really trying to understand
the Android layout framework I get that
you have to override methods like on
measure and on layout but what's the
class that's managing the entire
lifecycle ie what's the class that
measures the top-level container i canna
second sorry go ahead on your it all
yours yeah so just give me a second to
pull up the question
right so all your views are the
container would be a layout like a
linear layout or a relative layout which
is a view group so that will take care
of the responsibilities of calling the
methods unmeasured and on layout and all
the top-level view groups are managed by
the phone window manager which is the
framework class and that would manage
the life cycle of the view groups and
the views inside them and they are
really help imagining apart cool thanks
I'd also just like to bring up a couple
of pages that might be useful for this
person again if you go to you can see
the URL at the top developer.android.com
/ guide / topics / UI / / HTML and it
really gives you an overview on what
they view hierarchy is how its laid out
what the sort of relationships in that
view hierarchy are in terms of executing
the life cycle you'll see a lot of the
overrides exist in our in the activity
and also in the view so in the activity
for example you tend to call set content
view which basically goes and sets the
the top-level view in your hierarchy
there is actually a root node that you
can get from the window called the de
corps view but this is getting into
fairly low-level stuff so it'd be
interesting to just find out you know
from what perspective you're really
asking this question so check out the
activity documentation and finally also
check out the view itself the view
classes documentation because again we
go through in detail to say what all of
these overrides are and at what point
they're kind of called and I know you
alluded to sort of the fact that you
understood these ones from the view but
you might these couple of pages and it
might just help you give it a give you
the broader picture all right I'm going
to go back to questions and we are at
Andrews question which is on Android 2.3
and 3x
I can use the audio taxes successfully
inside a webview however when using the
same app on Android 4 points I can only
play the audio file once the current
time gets stuck at infinity after the
first play and can't be set back to 0
Andrew you there I am it either so I
think I'm understood this question but I
haven't actually heard of this problem
before so what I was hoping for was if
you can just want to give us an overview
since you're here you know what the
nuances around this are yeah but if you
can just provide a small sample that I
can reproduce this in it would really
help cool yep I can send you a couple of
lines of HTML at some point in
demonstrate of them it's really quite as
I mean I've got this web app damn
wrapping inside a an Android app and
it's going to be inside an unfair map as
well and but yeah just playing back the
audio files when you click on the little
hyperlink that I've got in my page it'll
play the audio fine multiple times on
android 2.3 devices and three-point
whatever devices are but as soon as i go
to a device that's got 4.0 or 4.1 and
you hit the play button and it plays
find the first time but then you can't
play the sound file again it cannot get
stuck it like i say one of the
attributes is the current time and at
the end of the first playing through
it's set to infinity rather than kind of
you know three seconds or whatever the
length of the sound file is and doing
searches on the web would indicate that
you can just set current time back to
zero to set this all the play head back
to the start of the sound file but that
doesn't seem to work so i was just
wondering if there's a weird freaky
thing I mean I've done lots of searches
on the weapons lots of people have
different ideas about various bits and
pieces but none of the tricks seem to
have worked so i start up okay so a
couple of things just on that then it'll
be great if you can also give us the sum
of those other references where people
are discussing this yet a step on Stack
Overflow can send you some links yeah
that would be ideal and the other thing
I was going to ask you is if you find
this up in the way
browser yep page the built-in browser on
ice cream sandwich and then also on the
on Chrome do you see the same behavior
on both of them yes yeah it's the same
on both so even though it's not even a
safe if you take away this all the
webview inside an android app parts and
just run it in the default browser you
still get the same behavior if you run
it inside Chrome or Safari on the
desktop it works fine that's quite
interesting so I must admit I haven't
heard this problem before I I only had a
chance to do a cursory search and I
didn't find anything but maybe I wasn't
looking for the right thing yeah no I'll
try and put together a little sample
stuff so i can send it through all right
great that that would be appreciated and
then maybe we can talk about it next
week yeah sure all right cool ah so let
me ask the Android layer question we
answered that one and all right we have
someone called gears asking how can i
make an android app efficiently this is
an interesting question and there's
there's several ways that you could
interpret it first started let me just
say that also a very broad question in
that you know there's no one simple
answer and in terms of being efficient
about making it it's good for you to go
through the docks so one way to
interpret is how do i have can i be
efficient in the way that I developed
this app so make sure you're well aware
of sort of the AP is that you're using
we have a ton of best practices around
you know developing for Android to make
sure you're familiar with those
familiarity with eclipse is also useful
thing in a multi developer environment
you want to use a robust version control
system but you know there's there's no
one magic answer in terms of how to make
your your app itself efficient which is
the other way you could interpret it
well again there's a ton of best
practices around there but some of this
sort of the basic ones don't do a lot of
work in the
in thread because that's also the UI
thread so if you're doing a lot of
processing or you're doing anything
across the network make sure that you
are doing that in a background like you
can use an ASIC task where you can use
threads there's a number of options
there so make sure you utilize those
don't reinvent the wheel you know if
there's some good libraries out there
then utilize those they'll often they're
quite heavily optimized as well you know
again this is a very broad question when
it comes to layouts in you I we've seen
developed a sort of make the mistake of
nesting tons and tons of layouts so you
know linear layout within linear layout
within linear layer um that's just
really inefficient and and it's quite
expensive too so you know those are the
things that will tend to slow down your
your app I need is there anything you
want to add to that one yeah just a
quick things so if also you're working
with a lot of data and you for example
if you have a news reader app and you're
fetching articles do do use the sink a
wrapper in the same service because we
design it very efficiently and it
matches the request from different apps
together so that device is not waking up
every of them so yeah do use some of
these framework components that you have
instead of you know pulling your doing
your question with timers or backgrounds
yeah and regarding tools what I'm to
mention we have awesome you to the
systray stool with the jelly bean and
it's really good if you want to analyze
the performance in the memory of your
application so do look into those tools
before you release a profile your app
and optimizes there yeah thank you all
right we have a question from fulham in
hong kong in the i/o 12 app there is an
action bar / spinner depends on whether
you're in vertical or horizontal murder
and on the action bar and a view pager
however the tabindex will update when
you swipe on the viewpager the spinner
is not updated
will it get fixed so it seems to me like
from here is basically reporting a bug
on the IO 12 app thanks for reporting at
from I would it would probably be best
if you actually report it to the project
page itself because the the engineers
that sort of built that up are actually
not in this hangout and you obviously
know the sort of right test steps on how
to reproduce the bug so I would suggest
you go there you may even contribute a
patch if you if you want to it is an
open source project so yeah I would say
engage in an open-source manner okay
next question for a person that has not
written a single java application is it
beneficial to use the ndk using native
see as I believe to write an app can it
be effective as one using the SDK and
writing Java code um interesting
question so it's you know I guess one it
depends on your skills using the the NDK
it requires a bit more set up the
developer experiences is well the
learning curve for developers is a bit
steeper so knowing the language is one
thing that you still need to understand
how the tools integrate how you set up
build system how you debug those apps
you know how you interoperate with
between the native app and the sort of
the framework of Android and in general
I think it's it's actually harder to
learn all of that rather than sort of
learn Java again I mean that's a
generalization it depends you might be a
really awesome see coder and you're
familiar with all of these sorts of
things and so you might find that more
useful probably the answer is give it a
go and see how how it turns out I think
it'll probably be easier though to start
the Java side of things that the tooling
is a lot better and there's just fewer
points of failure yeah put it with the
NDK stuff yep and is there is it a lower
level kind of API than the one that's
exposed through java I mean or is it
just a see interface to the existing
things like location manager and all
that kind of stuff or is it kind of more
low-level than that it's it's a bit of
bit of both actually and so we expose
some of the capabilities of the
framework to the to the NDK suru for you
see in C++ code but not everything is
there so some of it you end up having to
build J&I wrappers and doing you know
going back and forth yourself and not
only is that a little bit more work but
then you now have to start considering
the performance cost of going No
marshalling through that through that
space all the time so yeah it's a bit of
both okay um next question I see we've
had a few more people join us so before
I go ahead with the next question would
I be never or shalini you guys have any
questions to ask yep Michael she was
related to view flipper which was
introduced as an extension mm-hmm I was
just going to ask actually of what I'm
trying to do is I have a adapter
assassinated to my new flipper new pager
soil I'm vegetarian at I'm trying to get
the last created fragment on a
particular page let's say on h2 I have a
fragment which is there and i'm at a
reference of it what will be the most
optimal solution for that because i'm
not able to get it when i say get for my
iphone my adapter I get a new fragment
and then I'm trying to get it in the
sick section then result available at
all that's interesting um so you would
typically I would suggest that whoops
my lights have gone out that's not so
good hey honey what do you want to just
take over for a second so I'm guessing
in your adapter you have coded to say
the get will be done based on the index
of the pager will it run a new instance
yes you could possibly manage it is
registry of the instances and return the
instant already created I mean I guess
that's a part of your adapter
implementation and yeah so instead of
saying case was solution at this part
time is that I am painting the kind of
array array list which is keeping up the
track of fragments that were created and
then if the fragment is already created
after turning the value was dead
particular fragment that seems to be a
fair implementation to me I mean are you
incurring any kind of performance hit
there or my pointers in case when I'm
trying to access this particular
fragment directly from you flipper by
saying something like this again
alright if I try to say a beautiful bird
or get current item did you toss me the
index and if I say get item at and
to-dos the fragment this one API in that
if you so what I would actually suggest
is rather than getting it from view
pager I would actually try to get it
from the fragment manager so when you
instantiate it you can you can specify a
tag and then I would try and do a find
fret what is the time frame of my tag or
aspire dad for this because at the time
of instantiation described meant I just
at the time you say get item adapter
itself gives a like what id do it I see
so the main use of is your fragment a UI
fragment or is it just a class that
you're sort of using a you ipad so these
UI fragments are going to get recycled
so i would suggest sorry yeah so i would
actually suggest if you're trying to get
something very specific then your
solution kind of work it seems like not
the right thing to do because the whole
idea of a view pager is that it will try
and hold onto you know the page the
content for the pages only while it
needs them so typically what I've
noticed is that if your current page and
one on either side it sort of T tends to
keep so if you've got things that are
you know more than two off your your
current page it'll actually try to
recycle and reuse those fragments and
that's probably why you'll get the
methods are calling I'm sorry returning
a new fragment because the existing one
has been recycled but then how can I use
the same instances if I always get a new
one so if I've got to modify something
on that particular fragment so this is
kind of the difference between sort of
separating out your UI in your data
layer if you're presenting some
thing I mean typically what you're doing
with those adapters is that you're
mocking the data is dirty and then
you're just asking the fragmented you
know repopulate and redraw itself so
rather than directly sort of modifying
you know some state on your frame what
I'd be doing is changing the data in the
background and letting it flow through
the adapter so that when it's presenting
that particular frame when it's going to
get the fresh data but but for example
what would the issue will be with this
thing is that I have something on my
foreground as a UI it worked get
refreshed under lyst my butt up disputed
that particular fragment is created
again so that will again lead me to a
different kind of a problem um are you
calling notified artist it changed and
I'm calling them but it is not to
officially change interesting are using
custom views by any chance within the
fragment oh no that's all Bonnie w's
yeah because what should be happening is
you call notify data set change it
should come through and basically you
know redraw the views I placed even some
locks in order to see if i can get this
jet view quality for the adapter but
even that will not have a good item
called again but even that was not
happening so I was like okay for today
yeah it almost seems like the what
you're wanting is a static set of
fragments and you're using the viewpager
for that the view pages is is something
that typically tends to recycle
fragments and discard them when they're
not being used so it's almost like
that's not a good fit and i would i
would try and have a layer of
abstraction that sort of says hey this
is this is a statically defined
allocated set of fragments and then try
and link them up so in a sense of what
you're doing with your array list isn't
so bad i just hope that the glue between
the viewpager and that list is is
correctly manage
and before this I was I just wanted to
ask when a maybe it's a stupid question
but what is happening is a difference
between pragmatist eight-page a topper
and fragment paging dr. fragmentary what
was the first one fragment state major a
doctor and let me chop it up it's an
interesting one I'm not used the state
pager adapter have you on you it how
same I haven't used it but I know it's
one of the options available in the view
pager vibrates in shape of the fragments
are you helping me some sense i got it
from some blogs and i just put it
because the previous one was always
returning me with the some different
kind of values and what exactly i wanted
it's giving me with that but white is
giving me a no idea so i was just
curious about it what exactly is the
difference between these two yeah sorry
i neither of us know off the top of our
heads we need to look into it and get
back to you why should i make it help me
one more thing I was just having a
question I hope I'm not taking too much
of yours once again what is different
between view animator you flipper and
view suture because apparently all three
of them have been working something like
similar to each other so it's a
whataburger points you flipper so view
nmn it does a lot more than just
flipping views of view flipper is
literally you know I've got a list of
use and I just wanted to say go from one
to the next and the next in terms of
what I show view animator you can do a
whole bunch of like different types of
animations there and you switch ur I
don't know if the top of my head but I
think I before the animations see if I'm
saying I can still animate in and out of
a viewpager and usage of both of them so
we flipper and view animator in both of
them I can do in and out an emissions
and they will be doing almost the same
jobs I was like is there any specific to
princess and of API level or something
like that I when you save you animate
are you referring to the view property
animator that we introduced in honeycomb
you animators a transition in
transitioning
yeah that you have traditions one of the
transitions idea yeah sorry i'll need to
look this up and get back to you unless
anirudh knows what i'd suggest is I'm
after after this hangout is complete i'm
going to send out the event for next
week's one if you can just put the
question in the moderator then it gives
us a chance to look ahead of time and
have something ready for you ketchup one
of the things is that view switcher can
have just two views to Chinese and I
think you forget have more than two so
that's one of one difference between you
switch ur and flipper it's that so yes I
think switcher can have the studios
which you can switch between and if the
creek and have more than two Chinese
okay alright so view any me time you
prefer the electron's thoughtful about
but researchers can support only two
views that's what you're saying like
this which is to Julius so you can
switch between those two in yeah and who
either you're hungry you have a dog yes
I have a dog sorry that's all right okay
next question we have a pink foam has uh
has added a few and they've sort of been
uploaded so i'll just go back up a
little bit it takes longer and longer
time after we load an apk for the update
and before it is available for download
why is it there's too many apps queuing
the new approach for APK up there the
answer is I don't know I didn't we
didn't realize that this was an issue
for me if you are online it'd be great
for you to let us know what kind of
times are you seeing a are we talking
from like two minutes to four minutes or
are we talking from two minutes to like
four hours I've seen something similar
as well over the past couple of months
it used to take about 15 minutes from
hitting the publish button on the
developer console before he would see
your app appear in the Play Store on a
device
and maybe another half an hour after
that before appeared on the web whereas
now it's kind of taken about an hour
from hitting the publish button to
appearing on the Play Store and a device
and then maybe an hour and a half or so
before it appears on the web see it's
just seem to be longer these days then
maybe six months ago okay let me let me
raise that with the team I I don't know
if anyone has read that before I wasn't
aware of that so really it's just you
know it's maybe it's just due to the
number of apps or something around there
these days or the number that are being
submitted yeah usually I don't want to
speculate it could be that it could be
that you know we have the security
mechanism bouncer that could be more
thorough now which takes longer I I
honestly don't know and i'll need to
find out but thanks for raising that
with us going back to the questions we
have one from soham mundo from bangalore
typically my service stops working after
a while after my appt goes into the
background and i need to acquire a
wakelock or use start foreground what is
the difference between using start
foreground on the servers or acquire a
wakelock on the service and you want to
start with this one honestly I don't
know the answer to this I have that's
all right um so I think one let's see
it'll be interesting to see why it's
it's being your services being stopped
if you start your service in a certain
way you can it kind of says hey it's
bound to this activity or bound to this
to this particular foreground process
and so when that foreground process goes
away your service will also stop so it
depends how you are you are binding to
the surface and how you're starting it
acquiring a wakelock on the service all
that my understanding of that all that
will do is stop the device from going
into standby I don't think that there's
a direct correlation between having a
wakelock
having your service stay running unless
you're acquiring the wake lock in your
activity in which case is not getting a
chance to background so it really
depends how your binding to the service
and if you are if you're allowing it to
sort of hang around after the fact
you're your main activities gone away or
not so I would look into that and one
way to look into this is just by putting
in a bunch of logging statements in
there see if there's a correlation
between when your activities paused or
stopped or destroyed and when the
service is is going away okay final
question I'll just read this one out I
don't we've already done this one it was
the one about native development
languages hmm I don't see any more
questions on there does anyone on the
Hangout have any more questions I just
had one that's maybe not related to
Android specifically but you mentioned
earlier about the Google+ SDK will be
coming out at some point in the future
for Android there's already kind of a
Google+ API which is hosted on Google
code I think it is is that just going to
be replaced or is that going to be kind
of in parallel or will it be some
crossover or what are you referring to
the the Web API that's there yeah there
seems to be a lot of rest services that
you can call to get things like comments
on various posts and stuff is that going
to go away or so that that Web API will
stay because what we're bringing out is
an Android API right now you can consume
you can you know basically consume it
like it's a rest service yeah but what
we're doing is building an Android API
which will give you all the niceties of
you know just having any like a method
call using the identity manager on the
phone or tablet so yeah there's nothing
stopping you from using that the rest
api is probably going to be a bigger
overhead using that then using the
native sdk when it's available
yep cool all right now before we wrap up
today actually we've got something a
little bit different we tried to do this
last week and we failed miserably we
basically had an interview that we've
done with the developer called Anna
mocha now I'm unfortunately going to
have to try something that's less than
optimum to play this and that I'm going
to do that I'm basically going to share
the the YouTube video do a screen share
so what I'd request is the people that
are on the hang up if you could please
mute your microphones because I'm having
to use the speaker and the mic super low
tech today to play this video yep once
this hangout is finished we will it will
be available as a standalone YouTube
video as well for you guys to watch so
I'll just start the video and let it run
its thing
Iowa apparently there are over today is
our first interview on call in a pack
gianna is cookie mask on such topics
right did to serve sultan and charlie
okay just please introduce your
organization yourself sure my name is
yourself of a cqi broke up and I'm over
there were rocks and publishes and world
titles Wichita Falls and our post below
90 salon other than Allah for minority
groups by muscle on tree petticoat
forest defense Denise and I most recent
I belong to pitch to attack see I am I
over John that's embarrassing hit by
buffering I had pre buffered this video
or so I thought let me just try once
more
see it's all gone I said oh hello yo you
guys out of food so Oh follow me so I
asked some of you describe this week's
fig it soon as we can download and uses
bucket paid and the monetization is for
jay-z in a power locks in a hair which
it puts not everyone dies we may have
some advertising also within the gate
the rich people can heat to cubicle
office and then was hitting revolution
of directors it's s is fun we have a
free tonight it's also when we were
moving online version and people to
experiment with the office so I suppose
you have are from experience share our
offer Slater this needs to be by beauty
every point your camera suspicion
respond where I want the company about
something any trace of you later and
that means and actually that's one on
you can hear it fast and the google
let's do that it's okay amazon in his
father doesn't happen on anything else
dollars at some so something can be
bachelor you know when i got it open for
example you should should we be cash or
cash all you can give yourself have
about half cashews better example
sometimes much at all let me touch when
were you loading a bit level for your
app is attached to your back all the
time and using crack for too long I know
you need a google verification crash
caused by some pants on you to that or
we will have all
I would watch that's all we have severe
appendage I new leash either you have
one available to get a thing that lets
say is when you have to control in a
program which is set up about it all we
do anything I think that's something
that that's really good right but Abby
care whether you come becoming a pro
haha it internally see high level
facilities that you have it at power and
fatalities easy task and be really here
is an animal wrong volatile contractors
pop this though specifically I don't
mind they will fight with all the other
thing you know what I'm saying is turn
around and 111 have you water style ego
ethnics a little bit left front of it my
number call me too if I actually thought
about my service or better yet use this
is the time in automation system
activity should please as your apps you
know against your highlights environment
it's one that we actually that can learn
from putting office when every great
effectively anything this is what we go
once you must really bad or wrong that's
not what I feel thanksgiving it's real
things so we actually have a tool it
helps we call us off then we can
actually customize never let me see
events and then we can a lot
in a mother thing you know who focuses
on our time each other you have a smart
device compatibility as you can because
what you see is that users in a preciate
roles within the arrow sister and if you
have worked as much of my spirit device
or nothing can be on you thank you you
know I want my mother back home to the
one-size-fits-all brother PT 1 choose
one of my spots whatever we do tomorrow
and market in either animal that gets
this job use this apartment where it is
expected because because you'll have a
yamaha tech auditions I'm a miserly a
lot Commission venue you declared your
you something sorry I can't have to
conserve corporations great I'll people
sharing all the way at last you we
brought about passing on about binders
with 1280 package on any display the
process I'm interviewed in 12 an
intuitive won't be really with a
libertine to the side you know once the
quickly respond to specific things with
interview which I've been putting even
be performing to protect when are only a
judicial because give some extent also
look at this you are only do one edition
much much more these variables will he
ever be honest to do so it may not be
that one who's Molly investor
theoretical infrastructure that early
photography yes that's obviously sadhana
mention that you bless you
I support and they have a habit how we
test long or beta and all the work
during our experience in education enter
the president he gameplay so don't you
soon earth not risen self-test
ingeniously was a warning to have one
here where you came in recently no
charters will move on themselves and
this this is active great aid for
curating because they don't have to or
manually drag things everywhere and you
can adjust the speed and skip levels and
such like that however this is not a
replacement for actual testing during
during the process but but what cemetery
with all of our heart it doesn't evilly
screaming destination I'm so these are
the door to evaluate on tonight indeed
it is you can but if this movie glad to
speak not of this world about do
something and so if you try to capture
motion we won't be increasing our
evolution at you with it and I'm at the
same time you know he yawns along here
automated let got a piece they really
see some of you didn't see an issue when
you have unique sense of I guess you are
so another get the message a beautiful
man not some battle there are
specifically so that any pieces
this is from Vita which is a North
Korean plan actually you know in terms
of larger than ng but you know pretty
much no not moving outside of Korea but
a lot of our users who do is use it like
a business of unique devices which is an
intern I have had to be make the pixel
camera all right so this is like no
villager similar things this are from
Tibet and this is some sharp aquos like
you know Tyga's expect we need to
version of the television that you see
it never be there looking up these are
really interesting devices which are
starting to pick up a gated Southeast
Asia a 7-inch what do we tell me in
Tamil on sutter channels are the 16
number but you wanna first I see it
devices together at seven ish another US
dollars now if you want to come a
quantity of others view more 7-inch that
I am sure you will be fine once not
along with devices you know I obviously
because I mr. Agassi the galaxy nexus q
haces fast-forward transformer prime you
know we go very high rectify success
because it is submitted when I shoulder
the Android ecosystem supports a lot of
devices and uses our routine for you
know be racing event and I would be that
their computers in them for one watch
television not favorable tanto is the
vice versa so I understand it as a small
devices beauti- means so on why would
you keep our power that they are not on
a verge of one of the girls at the past
as man hope will compute artifact you
look great which is your you're very my
angle maybe maybe focus on at first
let's go deal
and the other than Canada but one load a
lot excitement not all this is about the
show having done to really make you
think what you give yeah imagining of
our clothes are to provide your ass walk
along a wide range so what an
opportunity for so now if the device is
your most people divided to school where
I know and and e c8 someone hard enough
that day you see a mountain users using
what was perceived to be going devices
relative in other traditional exhibits
behind differences did you finally she
underwent devices maybe because of price
affordability nah I sense much more like
you know haha the commodity is you know
or high-end devices fair but militia in
tradition to hear the row atomizers
different Heather at least I don't know
any versus people as possible because
people have a mean I have the eyes and
what agility yeah and I found with on a
seven instruments the group leader and
romantic enormous not and that to some
extent is big honor of knowing the
ability for manufactures quickly did you
read a dissolution on price on features
and of it and how a region of the second
ready for so is it for my present so
thank you so much for your type of user
and sorta Angelica then you do not be
further further come here
alright so that was firstly we just like
to thank Anna mocha for helping us there
and being part of that we hope that that
was some useful advice you can see that
animal car is a developer that caters
for a wide variety of Android devices
many of which you wouldn't have even
heard of that we got to see some of them
and you know they were kind of sharing
their tips for success so if there's
anyone on here on the hanger right now
that has questions around the interview
or anything else that we haven't
addressed today and now's your chance if
you are watching this as a recorded
segment you can feel free to send us
some questions via the the Google
moderator link for for next week's show
as well so we have Andrew and Thompson
on the line do you guys have any
follow-up questions what alright well I
I think before we go though and you
would wanted to make an announcement
yeah hi this is the this is for
developers around national capital
region of india which is new daily we
are hosting a code labs on thur august
and this is on sdk and tools in st cape
for performance analysis and memory
analysis so otherwise the registrations
are open for the event and we have a
link shed uncle if you can bring that up
on the screen if you i actually can't if
you can just pop pop it in the chat for
this hangout then i can bring it up
right now Oh button do that yeah thanks
so anyway we will talk the link in the
post on G+ and you can register and join
us for the collapsar so I can you just
let us know you said in India but in
sorry which was at one event multiple
events how many cities this is one event
in your daily we have office in
gurgaon google office and will be
hosting it there and this is one event
for now that we are looking at other
events in other cities but we don't have
any plans right now okay fantastic and
we will make that the link will post it
on on Android developers the Google+
page will also post a link to that video
and allow you guys to submit questions
and so we can address them anyways
thanks for watching thanks for joining
those of you that were able to join us
on the Hangout and we will see you next
week just goes away by